bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
dans file echo l'émission qui revient
sur l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
les résultats de l'enquêté besoins en
main d'oeuvre sont plutôt positifs
dévoilé aujourd'hui ils prévoient des
recrutements dans les yvelines pour
cette année notamment dans les services
à la personne et le commerce
jusqu'à dimanche la semaine de
l'industrie permet au grand public de
découvrir les entreprises industrielles
du département nous avons suivi des
étudiants dans une société du groupe
thales à l'occasion des journées
européennes des métiers d'art nous
sommes allés à la rencontre de quelques
artisans de ce secteur
et puis nous recevrons virginie galinier
bonsoir vous êtes chargé de mission
prévention pour face à l'école une
branche des ondes de la fondation face
fondation agir contre l'exclusion
nous reviendrons notamment sur votre
action dans le cadre de la semaine de
l'industrie vous créer des passerelles
entre l'école et le monde du travail
avant ça on passe à l'épargnant
on passe aux informations économiques de
la semaine excusez moi
pôle emploi a dévoilé aujourd'hui les
résultats de l'enquêté besoins en main
d'oeuvre pour cette année 2014
l'île de france concentre 16% des
projets de recrutement principalement
des postes qualifiés ingénieurs et
cadres dans la recherche le
développement l'informatique le secteur
de l'aide à domicile est également bien
classés cette volonté affichée de
recruter en hausse annonce des signes
positifs pour la croissance
dominique degryse directeur territorial
de pôle emploi revient sur ces données
pour la région et le département avec
plus de 180000 intentions d'embauché
281-7000 on est sur un résultat qui est
en progression par rapport à l'an
dernier et puis sur les yvelines de
façon très spécifique on est à 25 1792
la la progression est quand même
significative en été sur moins de 20000
à l'an dernier
globalement sans que les chefs
d'entreprise qui ont été questionnés
dans cette démarche semble plus confiant
en termes de perspectives de débouchés
donc en concurrent en conséquence en
perspective de recrutement pour les pour
elles mêmes et nous vous l'indiquions
dans les titres et les principaux
secteurs qui recrutent le service à la
personne et le commerce dans le secteur
de l'industrie on recrute finalement
également à l'occasion de la semaine de
l'industrie les entreprises du secteur
propose au grand public notamment les
jeunes et les demandeurs d'emploi de
découvrir leur secteur d'activité et
leur métier un événement national
soutenu par le gouvernement lundi des
étudiants en bts ont visité le site de
thales avionics électronique al système
à chatou des images d'elodie moines on a
besoin de plus en plus de la crise et
donc repenser toutes les architectures
électrique ici on travaille chez t as
beaucoup sur l'avion du futur les
architectures électrique lundi ses
élèves de bts ont quitté leur salle de
cours pour visiter une entreprise
spécialisée dans les systèmes
électriques embarqués des avions une
visite organisée dans le cadre de la
semaine de l'industrie
un événement national pour faire
découvrir ce secteur au grand public
mais surtout aux jeunes
stéphane duguay a accepté d'expliquer
l'activité de son entreprise un moyen
pour lui de partager sa passion
très jeune j'ai connu une vocation pour
la technique
vraiment
un amour de la science est donc besoin
aussi de toucher les choses concrètes
et là je me suis lancé donc dans une
formation d'ingénieur et puis j'ai très
vite intégré thales cela fait maintenant
quinze ans qu'il travaille au sein du
groupe les étudiants sont familiarisés
avec le secteur mais pour beaucoup c'est
la première fois qu'ils visitent une si
grosse structure
c'est beaucoup plus impressionnant quand
je me dis on ne voyait pas comme ça à
grande échelle là on se dit d'accord il
va falloir peut-être bosser un peu plus
que ça ce qu'on voit à l'école et là
c'est pas pareil c'est le niveau matthew
s'est enchanté pourtalès le pari gagné
car pour le leader européen de
l'électronique de vol ce type
d'événement est un moyen de susciter des
vocations ton a recruté beaucoup l'année
dernière on a recruté plus de 100
personnes dont soir société theater
grèce on recrute des ingénieurs des
techniciens et donc ce qu'ils
intéressent justement cette communiquer
sur nos métiers au delà du site le
groupe prévoit de recruter 1000
collaborateurs cette année l'espace
saint quentin en fait peau neuve
créée il ya près de 30 ans ce centre
commercial géré par le groupe hammerson
a cherche à relancer l'activité auprès
après le départ de certains commerçants
et à se donner du coup un coup de jeune
nouveau logo accueil rénové installation
de bornes d'orientation interactive
arrivé larry wifi ou encore places de
parking électrique et services de
covoiturage
au total deux ans de travaux et 7,5
millions d'euros l'idée est également
d'intégrer skywest pour créer un centre
commercial unique
c'est vraiment une de lui donner une
cohérence de comme pôle commercial
régional
donc d'inscrire espace saint quentin et
le renouveau de skywest en fait faire un
pôle commercial régional fort qui
s'inscrit vraiment dans la dynamique de
la communauté d'agglomération avec tout
ce qui se passe à l'arrivée du vélodrome
en fait on va pouvoir communiquer sur le
nouveau positionnement de skywest nos
équipes travaillent sur l'aspect
architectural et programmation
commerciale est très rapidement on va
pouvoir revenir vers vous avec des
nouvelles très intéressante
le projet dont carey privé ouest a été
abandonné mais le directeur de l'espace
saint quentin sûr que de nouvelles
enseignes devraient arriver dans le
domaine de la culture et de la
restauration
des annonces devraient être faites d'ici
mai par son successeur
car hervé deniau quitte ses fonctions à
la fin de la semaine depuis les années
50 une compétition internationale réunit
tous les deux ans les meilleurs artisans
s'agit des olympiades des métiers
vendredi dernier deux jeunes apprentis
tenter de se qualifier pour la première
étape la qualification régionale des
images de patrick jacq de dix semaines
dans ce grand hangar attrape un chantier
un peu particulier ces jeunes apprentis
participé vendredi dernier aux
olympiades des métiers
ici des canalisateurs et des
constructeurs de routes s'affrontent
deux corps de métier mais les olympiades
concerne une cinquantaine de professions
différentes du bâtiment à la pâtisserie
c'est de mettre en avant les filières
professionnelles au travers d'un
concours et c'était une véritable
vitrine qui permet à d'autres jeunes de
voir ce qui se passe de découvrir des
métiers et aujourd'hui ce sont 68 nation
dans le monde s'ils participent ces
jeunes de moins de 23 ans passe la
sélection régionale
le premier de chaque catégorie sera
qualifié pour l'épreuve nationale a en
janvier prochain
mais baptiste pense déjà plus loin au
titre mondial
mon but c'est le brésil c'est rio donc
voilà si je suis qualifié là je mettre à
fond y'a pas de
pourquoi moi pourquoi parmi les critères
le respect des dimensions le bon
alignement ou encore l'esthétisme car
construire des canalisations et des
routes reste un métier artisanal notre
métier de constructeur de voirie demande
beaucoup de polyvalence et cet ouvrage
permet permet de vérifier la polyvalence
à la qualité de la polyvalence de du
candidat à la fin de l'épreuve c'est
baptiste et qui finit vainqueur de la
compétition canalisations un premier pas
vers rio
et pour cet entretien nous recevons
virginie galinier bonsoir vous êtes
chargé de mission prévention à face la
fondation agir contre l'exclusion au
service de face à l'école alors pour
commencer quelle est l'action de face à
l'école alors en fait c'est de
développer des passerelles entre le
monde éducatif et le monde de
l'entreprise pour essayer de valoriser
les métiers de l'entreprise aux élèves
du coup vous étiez et pour la première
fois partenaire de la semaine de
l'industrie
quelles actions étaient mises en place
spécifiquement alors en fait c'était la
visite de garage donc j'en ai eu un
renault donc c'était pour surtout montré
tous les services qu'ils avaient au
garage de trappes de renault parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de services entre la vente
l'occasion la réparation c'est un centre
aussi dacia des yvelines dont tu peux y
ait beaucoup de choses à montrer aux
élèves
on voit d'ailleurs sur ces images ces
élèves sont des élèves de troisième oui
un prépa pro au lycée
mathis alors prépa pro c'est une section
qui finalement initie aux métiers de
l'entreprise et qui organise tout au
long de l'année notamment des visites en
entreprises ont tout à fait il ya des
heures dédiées à sa durant toute l'année
et forcément c'est enfin normalement
c'est des élèves qui vont forcément
aller vers la voie professionnelle après
en lycée professionnel
ouais alors nous justement ces jeunes
que l'on voit donc d'un collège de
plaisir je vous propose de découvrir ce
qu'ils en ont pensé
nous leur avons demandé à quoi leur a
servi finalement cette visite à
découvrir des métiers autres que les
trucs de filles on entre guillemets
genre puéricultrice tout ça avec les
enfants et puis ça m'intéresse parce que
c'est ce que je veux faire de la
mécanique
plus tard on apprend fait les métiers de
la mécanique
si ça nous intéresse comme ça on peut
faire les études là dedans
alors du coup à pari réussi avec cette
mission ah bah oui complètement en plus
on avait une fille parmi tous ces
garçons donc c'est bien ça valorise les
métiers de l'automobile et compris pour
les filles une fille aussi intéressé par
ce secteur là voilà alors dans le cadre
de cette semaine de l'industrie ces
parcelles
c'est passerelle vers le monde du
travail était aussi à destination des
demandeurs d'emploi nous ça ne concerne
pas l'action de votre service mais dans
le département pôle emploi organisé
différents événements je vous propose
d'écouter dominique degryse responsable
territorial à ce sujet il ya des
difficultés dans le dans certains
secteurs industriels parce qu'on parle
de de licenciements mais il ya aussi
beaucoup beaucoup de secteurs
industriels qui recrutent en premier
lieu les pme donc on s'entre nos actions
visant à favoriser les recrutements il
ya notamment sur le territoire des
yvelines c'est plus de 6 % des offres
d'emploi qui sont dans le secteur
industriel et on a certains secteurs
d'activité je pense notamment à tous qui
est opération sur l' opérateur sur
commande numérique sur lequel on a dit
qu de recrutement structurelles c'est
400 offres d'emplois sur le territoire
des yvelines qui ont du mal à trouver
preneur et ont fait connaître ses
métiers ont fait connaître ses opéras
ses débouchés parce que ses débouchés
qui sont stables qui permettent de à des
personnes de construire des carrières
professionnelles dans des pme
alors donc des postes sont à pourvoir
mais c'est souvent la formation qui fait
défaut donc on comprend bien c'est
l'intérêt de se tourner vers ces écoles
votre action d'ailleurs ne s'arrête pas
à la semaine de l'industrie vous
organisés tout au long de l'année
différentes actions notamment des
visites d'entreprises
oui mais il ya également d'autres de
possibilités je pense par exemple à un
forum
oui alors ça a lieu pendant la semaine
de l'emploi c'est du forum découverte
professionnelle
donc en fait le but c'est de favoriser
les échanges entre des professionnels et
des élèves
donc les professionnels en règle
générale ils présentent leur métier qui
souvent sont porteurs dans le territoire
et les élèves ça permet aussi peut-être
de découvrir des métiers qui ne pensait
pas du tout s'intéresser à su comment
sont sélectionnés les entreprises alors
c'est moi qui les sélectionnent donc
après comme c'est sur une après-midi
spécifiques
il faut qu'elle soit disponible cette
année il ya eu cette entreprise en tout
et c'était surtout des métiers
accessibles par la voie professionnelle
et ça concernant du coup tous les élèves
de 50 ans qui viennent
alors là spécifiquement comme si dans
les locaux du collège gustave courbet de
trappes et que les collèges sont en
réseau cette année ça
ça a concerné c3 et c3 c3 le collège par
trois établissements voilà deux trains
alors vous organisez également classant
d'entreprise qui va un peu plus loin
qu'une simple visite
oui parce qu'en fait c'est tout
simplement faire cours dans les locaux
de l'entreprise donc ces deux à trois
jours en fait les cours ils sont
préparés est assurée par un binôme
professeurs et salariés de l'entreprise
donc du coup ça donne un peu une réalité
des matières qu'on peut leur enseigner à
l'école qui ne voyais pas l'intérêt
là c'est concret parce que les métiers
de l'entreprise se sont mis en avant
grâce à leurs salaires allaient à
comprendre finalement comment les
mathématiques pour les voilà métier par
exactement alors vous organisez
également grain d'entreprise oui donc là
c'est une entreprise
finalement qui est créé par les élèves
tout à fait oui là donc c'est tout au
long de l'année durant deux heures par
semaine et donc le but c'est de
commercialiser un produit et donc les
entreprises accompagnent les élèves tout
au long des étapes de ce produit vous
travaillez avec un collège spécifique
alors c'est le collège gustave courbet
parce que c'est un professeur qui a
impliqué dans cette action est donc ce
professeur travaille dans ce collège et
on travaille donc avec cette classe
alors quelques caisses et les
commercialise cette année alors donc
c'est un dvd sur les discriminations et
donc c'est sur le principe du sav d'omar
et fred
donc il ya 14 saynètes avec chacune un
thème sur les discriminations on pourra
le retrouver en vente
oui tout à fait alors on fait des ventes
samedis 10 et 17 mai à auchan maurepas
dans la galerie marchande est là
actuellement en fait on prospecte les
établissements scolaires qui sont aussi
nos cibles pour que les professeurs
puissent utiliser le dvd dans les
classes par exemple pour d'un échangé
sur le thème des discriminations avec
les épaules et j'ai le projet de gatlif
voilà exactement alors vous je sais vous
aider également certaines personnes à
trouver des stages
grâce à votre réseau d'entreprise oui
nous expliquer un petit peu pas par
exemple j'ai eu un élève donc il est en
bac pro électrotechnique et recherchez
un stage de six semaines pour
approfondir son milieu professionnel
donc j'ai contacté à l'aise parce que je
sais qu'ils recherchent surtout dans
l'électrique électrotechnique donc du
courage et contacts et à l'est
j'ai envoyé le cv et la lettre de
motivation puis il a été pris des jeunes
peuvent se tourner du couvert face pour
cela oui tout à fait oui donc l'appel
l'appel est lancé
voilà non ces passerelles donc pas
reliés entre le monde éducatif et le
monde du travail ça commence finalement
à se développer depuis 2004 2005 il ya
les spécialisations de dp3 alors dp3
pour option de découverte
professionnelle et 3 3 heures par
semaine
il ya également les sections prépa
professionnels dont on parlait tout à
l'heure
est ce que finalement les mentalités
changent à l'école alors je pense oui
parce que on essaye quand même d'ouvrir
le monde de l'entreprise plus aux élèves
et donc les établissements scolaires
font peut-être en sorte que que les
élèves et peut-être une approche plus
forte du monde professionnel après la
troisième par exemple s'ils doivent
s'orienter vers un métier c'est quand
même mieux d'avoir la proche de
l'entreprise pour ça et tout tous les
enseignants sont ouverts à cette
démarche alors pas forcément c'est ça
notre travail cdd afin de leur faire
comprendre surtout l'intérêt de
l'entreprise
avec cette approche des mondes enfin des
établissements scolaires et donc pas on
essaie de marcher pour ça sera entendue
elle a beaucoup
virginie gars derrière on passe tout de
suite au dossier la semaine
les métiers les journées européennes des
métiers d'art organisé le week-end
dernier nous donne l'occasion de nous
intéresser à ce secteur qui englobe
finalement des carrières et des
activités très variées
les métiers d'art bien présent en
ile-de-france ne concerne pas que le
secteur du luxe comme vous allez le voir
le dossier de la semaine a été réalisé
avec jonathan willeman elodie moines et
romain respini des tailleurs de pierre
des marbriers des chaudronniers au
château de versailles les artisans d'art
ne manque pas de travail le week-end
dernier les visiteurs ont pu découvrir
leur métier et comprendre comment il
resterait le bassin de latone un métier
d'art c'est l'héritage dans savoir-faire
élaboré au fil des siècles on
comptabilise 210 7 de ses métiers
artisanaux
c'est en ile de france que les
entreprises de ce secteur sont le plus
concentrées cent mille sociétés soit 20%
du total en france car la région
regroupe de nombreux monuments
historiques et musées ce tailleur de
pierre vit principalement de la
restauration
un miti patio à fur et à mesure qu'on
commence bon ben on est entraînés et là
une fois qu'on est mordu ses fines et
quoi on a vraiment envie de le faire il
a commencé sa carrière par le
traditionnel tour de france des
compagnons en 1986 aujourd'hui il doit
restaurer les pierres du bassin de
latone une partie est effectuée à la
machine mais pour les finitions le
travail reste manière on peut pas se
permettre d'avoir un aspect taille
mécanique moderne
on doit toujours toujours avoir un
aspect taille pour finir la marque voile
tailleur de pierre un métier qui n'est
pas si rare il existe trois mille
entreprises dans l'hexagone un salaire
de base proche du smic qui peut bien
entendu évoluer selon l'expérience
tailleur de pierre fait partie des
des métiers du bâtiment on est on est
des ouvriers du bâtiment après on a la
chance de travailler sur des sur des
bâtiments des fois un peu plus
prestigieux que nos collègues mais on
est tous on est tous à la même enseigne
faut pas l'oublier au stand des
chaudronniers philippe nous expliquent
comment ils recréent les statues en
bronze comme on peut voir ici ici cette
pâte elle était tombée mais on l'avait
donc on l'a on l'a remise en place
donc on a fait une soudure voilà on voit
la soudure ici et après le but c'est de
recréer les écailles pour recréer les
écailles il faut tailler le bronze dans
ce secteur aussi en utilisent des
machines et des techniques modernes mais
le résultat doit se rapprocher des
réalisations de l'époque
pour philippe aussi la frontière entre
métiers d'arts et métiers industriels
restent ténus la formation est la même
il a ainsi commencé comme chaudronnier
industrielle avant de se spécialiser
dans la restauration
il y à 14 ans les métiers qui ont
travaillé sur ces oeuvres là c'était des
métiers comme les métiers industriels
à l'heure actuelle donc les gens
ben gagner lors leur croûte en
travaillant sur les fonderies la
ciselure voilà est donc maintenant les
mets qui l'a 6 leur qui sont un peu plus
rare ciseleur d'horreur tout ça c'est
devenu des métiers d'art mais à l'époque
c'était assez courant dans l'atelier
annexe les fontainiers s'occupe des
canalisations du bassin olivier a lui
aussi commencé dans le secteur
industriel avant de se spécialiser un
cap2 plombier en poche il a passé un
concours de catégorie c pour intégrer le
service des fontainiers il n'y a pas de
formation spécifique c'est uniquement à
l'interview services conformes les
personnes à nouvelles personnes un
métier de transmission et c'est bien là
toute la différence avec le monde
industriel
un savoir faire unique des fabrications
limité et toujours la passion là on se
dise cette pièce là que j'ai un convient
de créer avec les collègues va durer
dans le temps
peut-être 200
peut-être 300 ans je sais pas parce que
d'autres qu'on a déjà démontré qu'ils
étaient d'époque et tenait encore
donc on l'a on fait quelque chose qui va
vraiment perdurer dans le temps ça c'est
une satisfaction
et pour tenir aussi longtemps il faut
s'inspirer des techniques artisanales
traditionnelles d'antan comme la soudure
à la louche
ce sont des techniques qu'on faisait à
l'époque qui ont été oubliés vers le vin
1930 jusqu'à 1990 et en laye à une étude
qui a été faite pour retrouver la
technique de cette soudure allouche que
maintenant les anciens du service nous
transmettre aux plus jeunes et insipide
pour vraiment maintenant garder la
technique dans le service ne plus perdre
la technique notamment pour faire une
soudure comme ça il faut compter à peu
près une quatre heures à trois personnes
pour en faire une
même les outils ont été reproduits vous
ne trouveriez pas dans le commerce il
estimé qu'il existe une cinquantaine de
fontainier qui connaît cette technique
de la soudure à la louche en france mais
la rareté de son savoir faire ne se
ressent pas pour autant dans sa fiche de
paie sont regardera le salaire on ira
faire de la plomberie parce que le vrai
plombiers sont le terrain gagne le
salaire les métiers d'art ne concerne
pas que la restauration
il recouvre de multiples métiers
situations isabelle et tapissière
d'ameublement à son compte depuis moins
d'un an
elle a installé son atelier dans un lieu
assez atypique
je vais vous emmener dans mon petit
univers c'est mon atelier de tapisserie
qui est dans la pépinière d'entreprises
donc ce ne serait pas un bureau mais
c'est un atelier dans cet espace de 18
mètres carrés isabelle coût des rideaux
ou des pièces de literie tout à la main
bien sûr soi savoir que moi je suis
tapis soeur depuis 30 ans j'ai donc mon
ca fait tapisserie d'ameublement
j'ai commencé mes études à 13 ans sorti
de l'école à dix sept ans et demi les
j'ai commencé à travailler tout de suite
j'ai été salarié jusqu'en 2012 et en
2012 j'ai été licenciée pour raison
économique et à ce moment là j'ai décidé
de devenir mon propre patron en 30 ans
de carrière isabelle s'est fait des
connaissances dans le milieu
des tapissiers décorateurs architectes
qui la sollicite aujourd'hui de la sous
traitance qui ne lui rapporte que 2000 à
3000 euros de chiffre d'affaires par
mois et s'est jamais suffisant c'est ce
qui me permet surtout de me payer de
payer mes charges payer mes charges et
puis pour l'instant le problème c'est
que je ne sors pas de salaire je fais
comme tout le monde en fait j'essaie de
me débrouiller en fait vrai que c'est
pas toujours évident pour ces machines
achetées d'occasion elle a dû investir
près de 3000 euros hors taxes pour le
loyer il lui faut débourser 900 euros
par trimestre alors pour se faire
connaître des particuliers isabelle a
lancé une porte ouverte au sein de la
pépinière dans la salle de réunion c'est
tapissière à recréer une chambre avec
ses créations
un moyen également de montrer son
travail à ses voisins de bureau
la gérante de la pépinière est aussi
conquise et ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'elle ou en bureau à un artisan
on a eu aussi une entreprise qui faisait
de la peinture sur porcelaine
donc non on est ouvert à tout type de
métier au contraire l'idée c'est de
diversifier et donner la chance à tout
le monde
nous quittons la ville pour la vallée de
chevreuse on y compte encore de nombreux
ateliers d'artistes guillaume boulet est
menuisier ébéniste sa passion le bois
cet atelier sont des héritages familiaux
900 recevrez un grand père qui l'a créé
dans ce lieu même de la cré c'était mon
arrière grand père mon grand père mon
père elle et moi il y a quinze ans cet
artisan à quitter la profession il
pensait avoir tout vu
c'était sans compter sa rencontre
inattendue avec un artiste français
florent pagny je travaille dans une robe
rose de clôture à l'époque et on a fait
une clôture chez lui et en a discuté et
puis ben on n'a parlé que voilages et à
m'amuser l'allemagne pas normal ça
guillaume se lance alors dans
l'ameublement en bois
une activité qui ne cesse de prendre de
l'ampleur c'est encore florent pagny qui
le pousse à reprendre l'entreprise
familiale à la mort de son père
aujourd'hui les deux amis collaborent
ensemble leurs dernières réalisations
ses meubles en bois de chêne c'est un
rêve
réaliser mes rêves quoi sortir une ligne
de meubles signés florent pagny
guillaume goulet franchement guillaume a
travaillé une semaine pour un seul de
ces fauteuils prix d'achat 4000 euros il
devrait rapidement être vendus car il
n'y aura qu'une quarantaine
d'exemplaires
le bois vient de la forêt de rambouillet
un stock limité pour chaque nouvel
arrivage il faut de 5 à 6 ans pour
sécher le bois mais l'objectif de cet
ébéniste n'est pas de s'enrichir il
réalise de 500 à 600 mille euros de
chiffre d'affaires annuel et emploie 7
personnes
je peux rouler en grosse voiture ça
m'intéresse pas seulement la menuiserie
pour moi c'est un métier c'est une
passion que je suis toujours en moi mes
week-ends chez je suis à caen j'aime
bien je suis tout seul dans mon atelier
j'ai pas mes salariés et je retrouve mon
atelier et y accueille avec à ces
moments là où c'est bien c'est quand je
travaille le bois pour lui exercer un
métier d'art signifie créé à la main
bien sûr des machines l'est
d'aujourd'hui mais les assemblages par
exemple reste en bois ici pas de clous
anciennes techniques mais matériel
moderne
les métiers d'art groupe donc des
réalités très différentes restaurations
création ou fabrication traditionnelle
si certains artisans du secteur se
positionne sur le marché très porteur du
luxe
d'autres arrivent difficilement à
joindre les deux bouts leur maintien et
pourtant le gage de la transmission de
savoirs faire ancestraux
une erreur s'est glissée dans le
reportage s'agissait bien de statuettes
en plomb on finit avec l'agenda l'abg
lance un dernier appel pour concourir
aux talents de la création d'entreprise
les entrepreneurs ont jusqu'au 30 avril
pour s'inscrire dans la catégorie de
leur choix
cette année cent personnes seront
récompensés en juin dans les régions et
10 au niveau national près de 400
experts étudient les dossiers pour
récompenser des réussites
entrepreneuriales et remettre les prix
allant jusqu'à 800 euros
et c'est la fin de ce fil est qu merci
de nous avoir suivis je vous retrouve la
semaine prochaine et c'est la très bon
week-end